- So I heard, I was reading
the pre-interview for this,
I had no idea that y'all
opened for me in 2005.
'Cause I feel like I just got really cool.
(laughing)
- No, so no one cared about us in 2005.
We were just coming up and
basically to get other gigs,
we listed the other acts
that we'd opened up for,
but that really just meant
- I love that.
- That we were on the outside
stage in the parking lot
while you were playing for 40,000 people.
- Still the same.
- But you helped us get
a lot of gigs after that.
- Oh my God.
- So thank you.
We owe you 20%.
(laughing)
- So, now you're on tour for real.
So tell us about Happiness Begins.
- Yeah so this has been
quite the crazy year
for the family.
Just a year ago right now,
we had just started recording
music together again
and looking a year later we're
finishing up the first leg
of a crazy tour and also
the album Happiness Begins.
But it all started with the documentary,
which we called "Chasing Happiness"
which was kind of just to tell
our story of our childhood.
You know, our father was a pastor
and we had a pretty crazy
journey in the church
and then into our music career together
and we had really no intention
of getting the band back together.
But after filming for a little while
and kind of healing some
of those family wounds
that were there from our years
of working together in the past,
we were able to look at
this with a fresh view
and really kind of all in
different ways find our happiness.
So, we went for it and it's
been an unforgettable year.
It's been really amazing.
- That's really cool.
Like not only, I get the
fans are excited about it,
but it's way more cool
for you and your family.
That's a hard thing to like,
I mean that's my road family over there,
and it's hard to all be
together all the time.
Especially when you're related
I can't even imagine that.
So that's really cool that this ended--
- It's really special to
share that with family.
- If the documentary,
would you have released it
if y'all wouldn't have gotten together?
- I think so.
I think, yeah, we had spent
money making it so we probably--
(laughing)
- You're like, "Yep."
- And I think it was an
important story to tell,
you know and that was kind
of the thing that to us
was so special about it
is there was no intention
to come back and do this
again at the beginning
but when we actually just sat
down and did the hard work.
You know most families have to do,
we all go through things
with the people we love.
Whether it's the family you
choose or it's your blood.
- It's usually the ones you love the most.
- Yeah, you gotta go through it.
And we did.
You know, we look at the other side
and we're all kind of in the
best place in our lives--
- I know, you're all married now!
- All married.
Brother's got two kids
and it's a beautiful time.
To have been able to go
through that with your family
is I think we're all really grateful
and aware of how unique it is
so, it's just been special.
- So cool.
I will say, you have like
the most famous family ever.
(laughing)
I was like looking at everyone listed
in your family tree, I'm like
(mumbles)
Those kids are gonna be, like,
they're not gonna know what normal is.
- They're gonna have some
cool aunts and cool uncles.
- It's amazing!
You all should have, you shouldn't,
but you should have a reality show.
I just wanna see it.
I just wanna watch the dynamic
of all those famous people
in one family, that's insane.
- I think the band might break up again
if we have a reality show.